I gotta say I'm diggin the purple outfit
thank you thank you and we know it's
always to honor Prince what would he
think of tonight and what would he say
cuz I'm sure he would call you
he probably cursing you like but not at
me but it's a lot of evil but he would
say he would say spike that's night that
that shooter sorry he would say that
it's got to be a wait a minute that's
from do the right thing you got both Oh
put those up put those up what one he
got a classic here tonight that is a
okay so let me say this let me say this
you should have won an Oscar for that
and we know that you should have been an
Oscar nomination at least for Malcolm X
now tonight how are we feeling well if I
if I'm just going by to love them
getting and the people saying spike this
is your night boom boom boom I feel good
because everybody has just assumed that
you've had a million in one Oscar
nominations because first time for
directing first Best Picture
crazy though you should gotten here
before look at my face how is he real
how is he really handling how is he
really you know one thing that was
really super
cute that I that I noticed is that
you're a big fan of rami malek you were
super excited when he went the bathroom
wait what makes you such a big fans you
love the movie nah we don't mean done
two films together so he's good for them
yeah that's lovely gonna do some more oh
yeah I can't write but I can't afford
them now haha you can you can spike good
luck tonight
[Music]
[Applause]